hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american superhero and fantasy movie
called sky high
the movie starts by showing a teenage
boy named will stronghold his parents
are the commander in jetstream two of
the world's most famous superheroes
surprisingly all this time he has not
developed any superpowers like his
parents which is unbeknownst to them
shortly after his best friend layla
williams comes to his house
she has been secretly in love with him
for a long time they decide to go to
their school together called sky high it
is a high school that exclusively
teaches teenagers with superpowers
later they are picked up by the school
bus
on their way they meet with other
students
there are magenta ethan and zach
meanwhile the bus driver tells them to
get ready because the bus they are
riding will turn into a flying bus to
get to sky high which is located on a
floating campus in the sky arriving
there they are harassed by a group of
bullies speed a senior with super speed
lash a senior that can stretch his body
and penny another senior who can
duplicate herself
luckily they are assisted by gwen
grayson a mentor during their student
orientation
it looks like will is very mesmerized by
her charm
after that they are led into a room to
do their initial study called power
placement it is a session to measure
their potential superpowers and
determine whether they will be a hero or
a sidekick
they have to show their superpower in
front of the class which is guided by
coach boomer will's classmates ethan who
melts into a fluid sack who glows in the
dark magenta who transforms into a
guinea pig and layla who joins the class
to protest the two-track nature of the
school's education system all of them
are assigned a sidekick
during break time there is someone who
keeps staring at will
zack informs them that his name is
warren peace whose supervillain father
was imprisoned by will's father aka the
commander then it is will's turn to show
his superpowers
because he lacks superpowers coach
boomer assigns him to sidekick
soon he learns from nurse specs that not
everybody gains powers
there are rare cases of those who have
both parents with superpowers but do not
inherit any superpowers such as ron
wilson the bus driver
when he gets home will wants to tell his
father that he was assigned a sidekick
but his father interrupts his
conversation
then his father shows him his hidden
trophy room which he calls secret
sanctum
there is a history of his father's
heroism such as various collections of
enemy weapons furthermore his father is
particularly proud of the mysterious
weapon named the pacifier which he took
from his science-themed nemesis called
royal pain years ago because will knows
that his father has high hopes for him
he delays telling him the problems
earlier
unbeknownst to the two royal pain who
has been presumed dead watches them from
a hidden camera in one of the other
trophies alongside a maniacal sidekick
named stitches
as we'll be friends with the other
sidekicks they introduce themselves to
his father in his house
however he seems a little dissatisfied
as he finds out the superpowers of each
one of them
as a result will ventures to tell
everything to his father hearing will's
confession his father immediately feels
disappointed in him however he tries to
explain that he still feels proud to be
a sidekick
the next day will is being bullied again
by lash and speed when he is carrying
his food lash makes him fall causing his
food to spill on warren because of this
warren becomes very annoyed and
immediately attacks him during the fight
between the two will only can dodge the
attacks so warren chooses to attack his
friend
fortunately will eventually manifest
superpowers sending warren flying and he
immediately sprays him with a fire
extinguisher consequently they are
called to the counseling guidance room
that night will is scolded by his mother
but then his father is so proud because
he finally manifests his superpowers
back to sky high he is subsequently
transferred to the hero track however he
feels sad because he has to leave his
sidekick friends
in his new class he is paired with gwen
she is a technopath who controls
machines with her mind it looks like she
also has feelings for will she helps him
to do his work and offers herself to be
his private tutor
soon he inevitably becomes popular at
the school and unable to hang out with
his sidekick friends
one night will and his family have a
guest who turns out to be gwen
at first she intends to help while in
doing his homework
eventually she has dinner with will's
family asking will's parents to attend
the homecoming dance to accept an award
for superhero of the year which they
accept
while walking back to gwen's house gwen
asks a lot to the homecoming party
sure enough he happily accepts the
invitation then becomes her boyfriend
at the same time layla meets warren in a
cafe which turns out that he also works
there
she then reveals to warren that she has
loved will for a long time and she wants
to invite him to the homecoming party
later but she is insecure because she
thinks that will is already in love with
another girl the following day we'll
begin spending more time with gwen and
her group thus ignoring the sidekicks
on the other hand leyla seems to keep
approaching warren to make will jealous
of her
on the night before the dance gwen
tricks will into throwing a party at his
house
he then plans to invite his other
friends to the party but gwen forbids
him because the party is dedicated for
hero only she instead asks if there is a
more private room for the two of them
finally he takes her into the secret
sanctum
when the two are kissing it is seen that
speed uses the opportunity to steal the
pacifier without being caught in the
meantime layla comes to will's house
intending to meet him
unfortunately gwen lies to her saying
that will has no feelings for her
knowing this she immediately leaves the
place and will not interfere with well's
life anymore will then finds out that
gwen has lied to layla therefore he
breaks up with her refusing to attend
the dance even though his parents were
invited as honored guests after a while
will's parents suddenly appear and force
everyone in the house to leave the place
will also tells his parents that he does
not want to attend the dance party he
also calls layla to meet him at the cafe
so he can apologize for what just
happened
there he instead meets warren who
reveals that layla approached him just
to make will jealous
later will looks through his father's
old yearbook and sees a student who
resembles gwen holding the pacifier
which he subsequently discovers has gone
missing
reasoning that the student sue tenney
was royal pain and that gwen is her
daughter he instantly calls ron to take
him to the dance party at the dance
party gwen reveals that she is actually
royal pain herself
during her confrontation with the
commander she uses the pacifier which
turns its target into a baby
she also says that she has waited many
years to exact her revenge
in the end royal pain takes over the
school assisted by stitches speed lash
and penny
she uses the pacifier to turn will's
parents the faculty and the students
into babies kidnapping them she also
plans to start a super villain academy
and raise the children as super villains
as revenge for being written off as a
sidekick in her youth but luckily warren
layla zack ethan and magenta managed to
escape through the air duct
a few moments later will arrives at the
school with ron and manages to meet with
his friends
he then apologizes to layla and teams up
with the others to save the day
not long after lash speed and penny find
the sidekick
warren tells will to face royal pain
while he and the others will face the
three of them
long story short warren and ethan are
able to defeat lash and speed
on the other hand layla who is angered
by penny inevitably brings out her
strength
it is revealed that she has the power to
manipulate plant life defeating penny in
the process
the sidekicks demonstrate their heroism
after royal pain sabotages the school's
anti-gravity drive and their powers come
in handy to restart it apparently will
discovers that he is jet stream's powers
of flight when he is thrown off the edge
of the school grounds by royal pain
using his new superpower he tries his
best to prevent the campus from falling
at the end royal payne and her hench
people are defeated and imprisoned in
the detention halls
besides that will's parents the faculty
and the students are returned to their
proper ages
will's parents also thank all of the
sidekicks and admit that they are the
true heroes the movie ends happily as
will and layla finally kiss by hovering
outside the school
last of all will explains via a voice
over that ron wilson later gains his
superhuman powers after falling into a
vat of toxic waste thus becoming a
superhero
additionally he and layla have become a
couple he and warren became best friends
and he and gwen who along with the other
bullies went to prison become
archenemies
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching